it's all about um
loss
and
and recovery
and you know coming back from a loss i
wanted to some something that had its
weight and i like prayed to god i go
whatever you know what
whatever lands in my lap i wanted to be
something spiritual it's so strange and
it landed in my lap don't sweat the
small stuff as heather's first tv role
in four years the lifetime movie which
premieres saturday tells the real-life
story of christine carlson co-author of
the best-selling book series who lost
her writer husband during a promotional
tour
maybe there's a lesson in all of us
we'll get through this
natasha beret plays heather's daughter
megan mccain is the executive producer
heather locklear i mean you cast a
casual icon in this movie she's so
beloved you know she's taken a break
from acting and you know she's gone
through struggles of her own and i
thought um that her sort of like rawness
and openness with her struggles would be
something that would be great for the
movie stop being acutely aware of the
choices you make and just have an actual
feeling
i have lots of feelings well i don't see
them your tv mom is heather locklear i
know i know she is the most kind
funny hysterical outgoing woman i've
ever met i mean we clicked
instantaneously how much did you dig
into your own relationship with your mom
and apply that to this oh completely i
mean my mom and i have the best
relationship and she's one of my best
friends but we definitely get into
arguments all the time where i'm just so
stubborn so it felt very like not super
out of character honestly
you